ahora voy a usar un diodo en un circuito
y veremos cómo resolver el circuito con
estos diodos no lineales aquí yo tengo
un circuito con una batería un resistor
y un diodo led así que emitirá luz y
este es un tipo de diodo hecho para
generar fotones de luz cuando corriente
fluye en sentido directo de hecho son
bastante geniales y te los encuentras
todo el tiempo en componentes
electrónicos entonces vamos a averiguar
cómo usar un led en un circuito simple
en este circuito tendremos un resistor
de 330 ohms una batería de 3 volts lo
que equivale a dos baterías dobles y
queremos saber cuánta corriente fluye en
este circuito también voy a poner
etiquetas a los voltajes de nuestro
componente tenemos entonces aquí bebé
qué es este voltaje en el diodo pr que
es el voltaje en el resistor es este
voltaje y ahora te voy a mostrar una
gráfica de la curva y b de nuestro diodo
aquí está la gráfica puedes ver que en
aproximadamente punto 7 volts la
corriente sube rápidamente entonces
vamos empezando analizando esto con las
herramientas que ya que ya conocemos las
de siempre entonces bueno vamos a
escribir algunas ecuaciones que obedecen
estas corrientes
para el diodo escribamos la siguiente la
siguiente ecuación tenemos que la
corriente es igual a jesse que
multiplica
^ cfe sobre k t
-1 esa es la característica ibex para el
diodo donde este bebé es el voltaje en
el diodo
es decir para el diodo tenemos la actual
en función de bebé ahora la ecuación que
corresponde al resistor es igual a ver
sobre 330 oms es la ley de ohm aplicada
a este tramo al tramo del resistor y
ahora podría igualar estas dos
ecuaciones y resolver para verde y ver
de alguna forma -ha pero en lugar vamos
a resolverlo de manera gráfica entonces
aquí está una gráfica del diodo
este es el jefe es decir el voltaje en
el diodo este es el eje y el de la
corriente y quiero tabular la curva y ve
que describe el resistor en esta
ecuación yo tengo br en lugar de vd así
que bueno voy a trabajar con pr quiero
yo escribir a ver en términos de vb y
puedo escribir a ver en términos de 3
volts menos bebé
muy bien ahora vamos a sustituir br en
esta ecuación baja y la ecuación en
términos de la ley de ohm es decir la
corriente en el resistor resulta ser
simplemente voy a sustituir br y es
igual a 3
vd sobre 330 oms entonces y es igual a 3
sobre 330 menos bb sobre 330 y ahora
observa que esto ya empieza a tener la
forma de una ecuación lineal entonces
bueno sigo y es igual a menos veces
sobre 330 más 3 sobre 330 que es igual a
9000 amperes y esto ya es la ecuación de
una recta la pendiente es menos 1 sobre
330 la ordenada al origen está en 9
emiliano pérez
y ahora vamos a graficar esta recta
esta recta es llamada recta de carga
baja es el nombre dado cuando tú tienes
un resistor conectado a un suplemento de
energía arriba y colgando tienes un
resistor y obtienes esta ecuación
característica de una línea que tiene
una pendiente negativa
así que gráfica mos esta recta dado que
esta es una recta basta encontrar dos
puntos por los que pase la recta para
poder trazar la recta entonces para
hacer eso voy a igualar a bb a cero
entonces si algo puede igual a cero y es
igual a 9000 amperes aquí esta vez de
igual a cero pasará por 9.000 amperes
es este punto en la recta si hago igual
a 0 es decir estoy sobre el eje del
voltaje entonces veo el circuito y fui
analizar
sí y es igual a cero quiere decir que no
hay corriente en el resistor quiero
decir que no hay voltaje en el resistor
baja entonces este voltaje será igual a
este voltaje y yo conozco el puntaje
aquí es de 3 sports por lo tanto el
voltaje aquí es de 3 sports también y
eso lo sé porque yo sé que la corriente
es 0 ahora te hablemos este punto cuando
y es igual a 0 de estrés volts
aquí tenemos este punto en la línea
entonces bueno ya tenemos los dos puntos
y ya podemos trazar la recta que pasa
por ellos esta es la recta de carga
para el resistor de 330 oms ahora
recuerdas lo que dije de las dos
ecuaciones sobre igualar las recuerda
que dije que podíamos igualar las y así
resolver estas dos ecuaciones por el
método gráfico trazando las con la misma
escala y ver dónde se se cruzaban donde
se interceptaban entonces se intersectan
aquí y esta es la solución a nuestro
problema ya lo encontramos así que este
punto de intersección es nuestra
solución es donde la corriente en el
resistor y la corriente en el diodo son
iguales obtenemos una respuesta bastante
exacta aproximadamente 0.7 volts y la
corriente aproximadamente 6.8
miliamperios de corriente es lo que
tenemos y bueno listo ya resolvimos el
circuito con diodo utilizando el método
gráfico ahora voy a borrar esto que
corresponde al fragmento del resistor
y para nuestra solución tenemos
e igual a 6.8 milián pérez
eso es la corriente y el voltaje del
diodo fed es igual a 7 volts y bueno ahí
ya tienes la solución gráfica del
circuito con diodo terminamos